the first known boat to actually
navigate underwater was of course built
by a Dutch dude Dutch man they're just
so good at Water 150 years later over
here in what was soon to be the United
States George Washington paid for this
sucker to be made for his army the
turtle because it kind of looked like
two turtle shells put together so cute
the guy in there is just like so cozy
they tried to use the turtle in their
War for Freedom against the British but
it never really did anything useful and
then it just sank cool name but wasn't a
super useful submarine but it paved the
way 50 years later we have the American
Civil War where the Confederate Rebels
built a sub that was powered by a bunch
of guys manually turning a crank and on
board it had a long Spar torpedo don't
be fooled though Spar torpedo was just a
fancy way of saying a bomb on a 15-foot
stick and they actually used it they
snuck up on a Yankee ship with their
bomb stick in the middle of the Civil
War and blew it up and both sides sank
like the submarine sank too like it
didn't work I mean it kind of worked but
just generally work